- [Mark] Is the prostitution
to support the drug habit?
- No, no. I get a thrill off the sex, too.
Just the fact of a new man every time.
- [Mark] There's something
exciting about it?
- It gets me off every time.
I've been with more than 4,000 men.
It's a lot of people.
- [Mark] All right, Ginger.
- Yeah
- [Mark] Ginger, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- Compton, California.
- [Mark] Compton?
And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents
when you were a kid?
- Back and forth.
They had shared custody.
Most of the time, the weekdays with my dad
and then the weekends with my mom.
- [Mark] How would you
describe your childhood?
- Fucked up. Real fucked up.
I didn't have my mom like I wanted her to
and I'm doing the same thing to my kids.
I'm doing the same exact thing.
I'm messed up myself, I mean
I never spanked my kids, but
I'm not being, it's
like a repeating cycle.
I hate myself for that.
It's not like how I planned
it when I was 19 years old.
I wanted to be the perfect mom
but things don't go
well when you plan 'em.
They never do for me at least.
- [Mark] What kind of stuff
did you go through as a child?
- My dad used to whup me and hit me a lot.
Anywhere, like across my head.
My sister would come home from school
and she'd peed on herself,
so I would try to hurry up
and put her on something
else and he would catch me
and he'd whup me for that.
I was abused.
- [Mark] Physically?
- Yeah.
Verbally too, verbally too.
He would leave us, I'd wake
up in the middle of the night,
four and six years old,
and he wouldn't be there
and I'd be screaming for
help out the doorway and...
It was fucked up.
- [Mark] You went on your own at what age?
- Huh?
- Around 15 I moved in with my mom
because I told the social worker
that my dad was hitting me
and beating me too much and
I got sick and tired of it.
His wife at the time,
Tammy, I couldn't stand her either.
I was suicidal.
I was being visited by a
psychiatrist in the ninth grade
that my grandmother hired to speak to me
and pull me out of class
every once in a while.
It was horrible.
- [Mark] And then you were working
as a prostitute since when?
- I've always wanted to be
a hooker since I was seven
but I worked as a prostitute since I was,
give or take, 18 years old.
I'm 40, going on 41 now.
- [Mark] And how did that start for you?
- Started off as men pulling
over and offering me money.
And it went from there, I
had a couple of pimps and...
It was just too much. My
life has been very busy.
I haven't stopped. It's
called being turnt out.
I can't stop, it's like a magnet.
It's hard.
It's not hard to stop for
some people, but for me it is.
- [Mark] What is it that draws you to it?
I've heard a lot of people say
that they're addicted to the lifestyle.
- I'm addicted to the money,
addicted to the fact that
I'm gonna do the same thing
over and over and over and over and over.
I'm not addicted to the fact
that maybe I'll get in the car
and they might pull a gun on me again.
I've had four guns drawn on me,
the last one being a TEC-9.
And I asked him to, it was stupid,
but I asked him when he's ready
to come back and apologize,
and he did, and I dated him still.
That's how risky my life
is and how much we gamble.
I'll do anything for the money.
It's fucked up.
- [Mark] Are you using crack?
- I use all types of drugs.
I don't let that get the best
of me because it shouldn't,
but that's not the
reason why I'm doing it.
It's not the reason why.
I was doing this way long before.
I mean, I started smoking weed at nine
and smoking cigarettes at seven.
- [Mark] But the harder
drugs started when?
- 16 years old, in my senior year
at Ganesha High in Pomona.
- [Mark] But you're saying
the prostitution started--
- Started at 18.
- [Mark] Yeah, but which one caused the--
- 17, 18.
- [Mark] Is the prostitution
to support the drug habit?
- No, no. I get a thrill off the sex too.
Just the fact of a new man every time.
- [Mark] There's something
exciting about it?
It gets me off every time.
I've been with more than 4,000 men.
It's a lot of people.
It's a lot.
- [Mark] What do you think
having 4,000 sexual partners
does to a person?
- Wears them out. (chuckles)
Wears you out. I'm--
- [Mark] No, but mentally.
- There's nothing someone could tell me
about the male anatomy, I
know it from front to back.
There's nothing.
Not even the man himself.
He ends up giving up
like, okay, you got me.
I'm like, look, I know already
what's about to happen.
You either can hold it in or not.
I say, but I know what you do, you know?
And they usually give up.
I've had some good
experiences and some bad ones,
but I'm not gonna let the bad
ones override my good ones.
- [Mark] Do you respect
the men that take you out?
- I totally respect them to the fullest.
They're lonely and they need love too.
Officers pick me up too, you know,
all walks of lives you got.
Every organization you can imagine
that I've been picked up by.
I wouldn't rule out nothing,
I'm saying every agency,
every organization,
they know who they are.
They know who they are, and
we're good friends to this day.
- [Mark] And you know
how to keep a secret.
- I'm not gonna say the
name of the officer,
but they know who they are.
And I'm just highly affiliated
with a lot of things.
- [Mark] They're probably
watching these videos.
- Probably.
- [Mark] So you--
- But we're still friends.
- [Mark] What's the
craziest thing you've seen
in all your years of doing this?
- Whoa, I've seen some crazy.
I've been in things
that're crazy. I've seen
one of my dates go as far as
him throwing body parts in the trash
and talking to me at the same time.
It doesn't bother me because
to maintain the sanity
and not get into that position,
you must act accordingly like a lady.
I mean, I've had some
crazy serial rapist say
"You know what, you're
crazy to me, get out!"
And I didn't find out
that they were like that
until I seen the description on the news.
I'm like, "Oh my God,
I just dated that guy."
And I became one of the survivors
out of a lot of situations
because I knew how to conduct myself.
I'm crazy for being with a crazy person.
- [Mark] What do you think
there was about your upbringing
that put you on this path?
- Well, I mean, being molested
by some family members,
and going to the bathroom
and seeing a bunch
of dirty magazines in there,
growing up watching Elvira.
- [Mark] Yeah, but most
seven year old girls
don't dream about becoming a prostitute.
- My dad used to catch me in the bathroom
taking off my pants from school
and I'd have fishnets on.
And he's like,
"Where are you getting
these sexy stockings from?"
And I'm like, I didn't want to tell him,
but I was buying them.
I had a desire for sex since I was four.
I remember being at a little tea party,
me and my cousin and
my sister, and I said,
"When I grow up, I'm gonna
suck my husband's cock."
I don't know where it
came from, but it did.
And that's what I totally meant, you know.
There are all types of girls in this world
that have sexual desires
at a very young age.
I didn't mind having
orgasms at the age of 13.
Most women are still trying.
I'm like, "Wow!"
What's the whole game behind it,
I mean, it's easier than you think.
- [Mark] So you think your
genetics just led you there,
or is it the molestation?
- No, it's just the whole turn
on about it, like sex period.
I just, I'm into it.
- [Mark] You're into it.
- I'm into it, like I want pleasure.
I really love sex a lot.
I can't hide that about myself.
I find it interesting since I was a kid.
I liked the whole, how people
go through their whole acts
and then to have sex, you know, like
I was running across the
street like two weeks ago
and I said, "Suck my cock,"
but I was having a moment.
And this mother-fucker, he
picks me up and he said,
"I'll suck your dick."
And I get in the car and he
starts dolling himself up
putting a wig on and stuff.
And I said, "Well, what am I gonna get?"
He said 60,000 fucking dollars
that I gave up for a date.
Yeah, last week I did one for 1300,
just to stand around and smoke crack.
- [Mark] So the guy who
offered you, how much?
- 60,000.
I think it was to go to Calabasas.
He was, he had money.
And I said, you know
what, I was just venting,
you know, I really don't have a dick.
He goes, "Well, I'll eat your pussy."
And I go, "Oh my God, I go.
I didn't want to go that far
even though I could have.
- [Mark] It's a long drive.
- There's been a lot of
dates that I've thrown off,
millions and millions of dollars.
I just wasn't feeling it.
I didn't like the distance maybe.
- [Mark] Right. But
with all these partners,
all the business that you've done...
- I'm clean as a whistle.
- [Mark] Have you saved money?
- I've put it towards other things.
I've probably made other millionaires.
Invested in some things.
There isn't one person
that don't need a hooker.
No one's exempt.
And it's to the point where it's like,
get this straight, I have my own life,
I'm not a fucking robot.
I too have feelings, you
know what I'm saying?
I cry, like anyone would,
and I have feelings.
Stop, you know, thinking I'm
some fucking mule, you know?
And I'm not, but I love what I do.
And my grandmother told
me before she passed away,
"Just whatever it is you do, be the best
"at what the fuck it is,
don't ever be ashamed of it."
And I'm not, I'm not.
So many people don't even know
that everyone's a prostitute,
everyone prostitutes himself
a day just to make a dollar.
You got to do it.
I just do things differently.
And I'm not a homewrecker.
No I don't wear Victoria
Secrets perfumes and stuff.
I don't wear makeup.
I'm just looking for my money and I go.
I'm not trying to break up
a happy home or a family.
- [Mark] Have you been in love before?
- Huh?
- I don't know what that
is, 'cause if I was in love
those people would still be in my life.
So unless love taps me
on the shoulder and say,
"Hey, I'm love."
No I don't know what love is,
and I've never been married.
- [Mark] How many kids do you have?
- Three.
- [Mark] Did you raise them?
- Somewhat. They know who I am.
They know how crazy I am.
They know their mom's a
prostitute and they still love me.
21, 17, and the 12 year
old is going on 48.
She's real mature for her age.
They know I'm a hooker,
and if anyone was to
down talk to me right
now in front of them,
they will rip your fucking head off
because I am who I am.
And always taught them don't
let nobody tell you different
that I don't love you, I do.
I'm just living my life.
I wasn't ready to have
kids early, or period,
I never wanted kids, but things happen
and I'm not gonna get no abortion
just because someone
thinks it's a bad idea.
I love my kids. My children, excuse me.
I love my children.
And nothing's gonna change that.
It tears me up every day to think,
you're not being present in
their life, you're a bad mother.
But I hope God understands.
I'm sure he does.
- [Mark] Are you religious?
- I believe in God, I
don't believe in Jesus.
That's it.
- [Mark] What do you worry about?
- My kids not accepting me.
That's all I worry about.
I don't have time to
worry about no one else,
but my children.
I check on them every once in a while.
Like I said, they know who I am.
- [Mark] Who raised them?
- I mean, their dad is
raising them currently,
the two girls, and my mom has my son.
He's 21, just got out of the army.
They're all good.
I call him every once in
a while, we're all good.
- [Mark] Do you have friends?
- Hell no, I don't know what a friend is.
I'm a Virgo, I don't
know what a friend is.
These so-called people last
three months in my life,
if that, and then they vanish.
So the only friend I have is God,
and me.
- [Mark] What's been the
worst time of your life?
- Never, nothing.
- [Mark] What's been the best time?
- Now.
I'm not in jail.
- [Mark] What's the most
important lesson you've learned?
- Just don't change for nobody and be me.
I'm not gonna sit there and change
or gallivant amongst people
that won't accept me.
If you don't accept me, you ain't got to.
- [Mark] It sounds like you feel no shame.
- I don't.
- [Mark] For anything?
- [Ginger] For nothing.
I won't stress or grow white hair
or bust a wrinkle for no one's ass.
Not even for myself. I don't
feel sorry for myself at all.
- [Mark] So you'd describe
yourself as happy?
- [Ginger] Over happy.
Even though I have tears for some things,
I can't beat myself up
on it. I gotta be happy.
I ain't in jail, so.
- [Mark] And you're still working today?
- [Ginger] I was working a
few hours ago. (laughing)
I stopped the date
actually to be over here.
He's still sitting over there.
- [Mark] So what streets do
you work, or have you worked?
Figueroa?
- [Ginger] Figueroa,
Sepulveda, Beach, Van Buren.
I made my own at Big
Bear Lake, Pine Avenue.
- [Mark] Just in case
somebody wants to find you.
- [Ginger] Just in case
someone wants to find me.
Holt, in Pomona, I'm
a real star out there.
- [Mark] I think some
of these videos function
as advertising for some
of you ladies, too.
- [Ginger] Cool.
I got major love for Holt Boulevard.
They got love for me too, they love me.
I left that city dry when I left.
Dry, all I heard was it's
crickets and tumbleweeds now.
So I guess that makes me a big part of,
I don't know, being a local
celebrity in some areas.
- [Mark] Tell me about your take on pimps.
- [Ginger] On what?
- [Mark] On pimps.
- What do you mean?
- [Mark] Like, do you think
having a pimp is a good idea
or what's the upside and
downside of having a pimp?
- I mean, I could be one.
For women who think that it's
a bad idea to have a pimp,
you're totally wrong.
What a pimp is, is a man
that will take care of you,
give you money, do all types
of things, bodyguard, whatever.
A woman out there alone,
which is a "renegade,"
waiting to be killed because
she has no structure.
And then that gives a man, supposedly,
a right on the streets to disrespect her,
which I don't like seeing.
- [Mark] She'll get killed by...?
- Guerilla pimps.
They work in groups, numbers,
and they'll dog walk a bitch,
just drag her ass and kill her.
I've seen it happen.
I've seen it happen,
I've seen women killed
because of my happiness being put at stake
and I couldn't get what I wanted.
And I've seen a whole
fleet of women get killed
all because they were taking
a meal out of my plate.
It's really not a game.
Out there, it's not a game.
Ain't no mother-fucking game.
So if you waking up in the
morning, you think it's gonna be
a good idea to be a
freelancing hooker one day,
you better look into it 'cause
you could seriously get hurt.
Just found in the dumpster
in the alley somewhere.
You gotta know somebody.
It ain't gotta necessarily be a pimp,
it could be folks, family,
that are affiliated
in the streets that are watching over you,
and you gotta make that known.
'Cause if you don't,
somebody can hurt you.
The person that won't do their homework.
- [Mark] This kind of work
is not for every girl.
- It ain't cut out for every woman.
You got to have it in your bones,
it's something you gotta know you can do.
I mean, you just don't wake up and like,
♪ pretty woman ♪
no, it doesn't happen like that. No.
- [Mark] Do you have
dreams of being saved?
Does that idea, I mean,
do you hope some guy
might come along and save you from this?
- Hell, no.
That'll only be God, my savior.
There ain't no man that
can do that other than Him.
Nope.
- [Mark] Do you have to be
crazy to do this kind of work?
- Oh my God, it's a gamble,
it's a risk every second of your life.
I've had guns pulled on me--
- [Mark] To me, that's what I'm hearing,
if you're doing so many--
- Knife,
I've dated mass murderers,
serial killers, rapists,
and I'm a survivor.
- [Mark] Are you turned on by that?
- No, like I told you, I don't
find out till after like,
(gasps) good thing I acted
presentably like a lady.
I mean, you gotta be a fool
not to know how to pass a test.
And for all you ladies
don't know what the test is,
it's if a man drops money on
the ground or if you see it,
do the right thing and hand it to them,
because you're gonna get it anyway.
Once you start thinking
you're slicker than them
or that they're not playing drunk,
they might cut your head off or kill you.
That's how usually it happens.
So do the right thing,
give them their money.
And when they ask you,
"Why did you do that?"
You say, "Silly, you're
gonna give it to me anyways."
And they most likely be like, here you go.
Don't ever fall for the okie-doke
and think that they're
drunk, they're never drunk.
They know, they've been
through this a million times.
You know, there's never
a dumb john out there,
they're always brilliant.
They just want to see where your head is.
- [Mark] Always some games being played.
- Not necessarily games, more like tests.
- [Mark] Tests?
- All the time.
Every move you make,
watch yourself carefully.
Don't go in this industry
looking for trouble
like that to begin with.
The women that are carrying
the knives, the guns,
they're looking for that.
I don't carry shit.
I ain't looking for nothing but my money.
Why do I need that to protect myself?
I shouldn't even be in that situation.
"Don't you need protection?" No!
Just do, be simple. Keep
it simple. That's it.
- [Mark] Your intuition is
probably a valuable tool, right?
- Very.
If I ain't feeling you,
I ain't feeling you.
- [Mark] And after 4,000
guys you probably get a
heightened sense of who's safe.
- Oh shit. I know where to go.
- [Mark] What do you look for?
- I don't go look for 'em. They look--
- [Mark] No, no, no. What
behaviors do you sense
are trouble in a guy, in a trick?
- I love tricks.
There's a difference between
the john and the trick.
- [Mark] What's the difference
between a john and a trick?
- A trick is a man who will
jack off rolling next to you
with his windows rolled up in his car,
and he's not gonna let you in ever.
And he continues to
drive around in circles.
Never gonna pull over for you,
unless you throw a brick through
their window or something.
- [Mark] But your definition
of a john is a guy who'll
take you up and have sex for money.
- Not necessarily, I'm not
having sex with all these men.
There's been times where
I've had to clean a house,
or be a nurse,
walk a dog,
serve some people papers.
Not necessarily everything a
prostitute is picked up for
is for that, sometimes they
wanna just sit and talk
and pick my brain.
Professors, not everything
is a sexual thing.
If that's what turns them
on, I'm there for it.
Other than that I haven't
had sex with all of them.
I sell dreams. I mean,
they're easier to sell.
If a man knows he can get you easy,
he ain't gonna be back.
Most of the men I've been with
for hundreds and thousands,
we don't have sex, he just wanted company.
And if you do have sex, it'll come.
But if not, oh well.
It's nothing
- [Mark] It's an interesting
lifestyle you lead.
- It's been one crazy hell of a life,
but everybody got to do something in life.
And I was just called to do this.
And I'm not gonna sit here and be like,
"Oh, feel sorry for me."
Don't, and if you do, then do, I mean.
I wouldn't advise it for nobody.
It's not for everybody.
- [Mark] All right, Ginger.
Thank you so much for talking with me.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] I wish you the
best of luck out there.
- You too.
- [Mark] Thank you.